- Hey guys, it's Gary and
I've got 50 seconds for you.
This is 50 seconds for
every 50-year-old in the world.
I need you to
understand something.
You have so much time.
I'm an entrepreneur-land and
I'm here with all these kids.
Show these kids,
show these kids.
All these kids and
they're taking
advantage of the new world.
Right? But they're
young and they're raw
and they've got a lot of great
and some are great and they'll
be all-time great but what blows
me away is how many of you have
decided that you're finished.
That you're on the
back end of your life.
That you can't accomplish it.
That this wasn't built for you.
I'm 41 years old.
I didn't grow up with the shit
either but I figured it out.
You figured out how to drive,
you figured out
how to be a parent,
you figured it all out
and with the health trends and
the way the world is now,
you've got a
long life in front of you.
So instead of sitting in
that job for the next 10 years,
go do your thing.
You've got plenty
and plenty of time.
(phone chimes)